when keeper Detlef Bauman calls them it
doesn't take long before the new
residents of the d'hubert's Heath all
come running the Przewalski's horses a
wild breed native to Mongolia arrived
first there followed by European bison
wild and shy creatures from the same
family as domestic cattle but like the
wild horses they're voracious eaters and
adapted to life in the wilderness
they're very robust very tough unlike
domestic cattle they can spend the
entire year outdoors without needing
shelter or extra food they get along
splendidly with the food available here
in the Heath they're ideal partners for
us when it comes to landscape
preservation the Debrett's Heath is
located just a few kilometres from
Berlin not far from Tegel Airport for
over a century military exercises were
conducted here first by Prussian
soldiers and later by occupying Soviet
troops now the Zillman foundation has
turned the 2,000 hectare military
training ground into a nature preserve
what's unique about it is that the live
firing often caused brush fires and
these created the ideal conditions for
large areas of Heath to develop the
habitat was just right it's a habitat
which should stay that way without human
intervention that's why the wild horses
and European bison were introduced here
known as mega herbivores these large
plant-eating animals prevent the heath
becoming overgrown with trees the Bison
in particular simply remove any young
trees blocking their path
they don't push them over they go in
here with their horns and then turn them
around it's pretty impressive
they play around with them you'd mind
any of the money you've had you can
always tell where the larger herds have
been by what they've knocked down a
couple they're supposed to do that but
you can always see what they've been the
idea is to protect nature and
biodiversity with very little money and
personnel around 50 kilometers south of
Berlin is one of the region's few lime
marshes
it's home to plant and animal species
found almost nowhere else that's because
the swampland has disappeared this past
year we've lost lots of swampland due to
drainage 200 years ago the state of
Brandenburg still had over 200,000
hectares of intact and growing marshes
today there are just a few thousand
hectares left
in the middle of this one is a small
herd of Asian water buffalo they've been
brought here to graze and eat unwanted
plant species not all conservationists
think it's wise to have Asian Buffalo
protecting German marshes but the
project's initiators view it as a
pragmatic solution worth trying nature
conservation is also in a state of flux
when environmental factors change when
many areas are globalised we
conservationists need to search for ways
to deal with these influences the water
buffalo provide a way to preserve
domestic plant species and preserve
natural habitats for other animal
species to a habitat in which orchids
grow once again thanks to the water
buffalo yet swampland like this can
quickly become overgrown and turn into
wasteland
so human assistance is also needed to
preserve the marsh
this is a young older which the Buffalo
don't eat to make sure we don't end up
with a big forest I'm cutting it down
back at the dirty teeth deadlift Bauman
and his team have attracted the wild
horses with some carrots they need to
check whether the animals are healthy
Przewalski's horses are practically
extinct in the wild so projects like
this one help preserve the 4,000 still
in existence around the globe Boy Scouts
wished would last year we sent two mares
to Mongolia to help increase the
population in their native land there's
now a herd again in the Hungarian push
it's not very large yet but its numbers
are on the increase so it's becoming a
strong breed again the area is
completely surrounded by an electric
fence
keeping the newly created wilderness
clearly separated from civilization that
too is a form of nature conservation